In book five of Paradise Lost
Milton's theory of, of, of monism.
That's the theory of the one first matter
that we looked at last time. Uh, this,
the theory of Mon ism or of
vitalism or animus materialism.
There are a number of, of terms for
it. Um, it arises in the context.
You'll remember, have a discussion about
digestion and I'll, I'll just remind you,
Adam's simply asked Raefiel how it was
that human beings good eat how it was
that angels could eat human food and
Raefiel responded with his radical claim
for the continuum of matter.
Um,
a continuum of matter and spirit in God's
universe and the process of digestion
was no more suggestive or suggestive
or important to the Archangel Raefiel.
Then of course,
it was four for Milton himself.
You'll remember that letter to the famous
Dr. Leonard Dolores in which Milton
and explained that it was his,
it was his bad digestion that he
believed was largely responsible for his,
for his blindness.
And,
and Milton's digestive theory of blindness
was actually perfectly reasonable
medical hypothesis in the, in the
17th century theorists of digestion.
We're continually arguing that,
that an escaped gasses could easily
rise up in the body. Uh, but,
but Milton's own adoption of this
theory served a particular and,
and I think an important purpose
nearly every, and actually this is, um,
this is a point that's made most
brilliantly in a book that I think Matthew
Valdiviez heads of it's by Michael Lee.
Please hold up the book because it's a,
it's a, it's a great book. It's
called the dialectics of creation.
And thank you for reminding me that I'm
indebted to leave for this point. Um,
nearly every important event and paradise
lost is represented in some way or
another as a process of digestion.
Raefiel tells Adam that, uh,
the Archangel says knowledge is as
food and that Adam is therefore ingest
knowledge temperately just to, as he
must, it's his obligation to ingest food.
Temperately um, and of course in
moderation, but it's not just,
it's not just knowledge. Everything
is digestive and paradise lost. The,
the process,
the process that we looked at last time,
the transformation of Adam and eve into
angels was going to be, as you remember,
the,
the product of a virtuous digestion.
But so too will the will,
the expulsion of the rebel angels be the,
their expulsion from heaven.
And when the son of God drives them
out with his chariot of paternal deity,
they are essentially eliminated his waste.
They're purged from the space of Heaven.
And Milton fills his account of that,
uh,
of that explosion with really
all of the scatology that he can,
that he can muster.
And even the last judgment
will be described in terms
of a process of digestion.
The saved will be assimilated
into the body of God,
into the body of the universe. And the
dammed at the end of time we'll be,
we'll be excreted into hell.
And Milton is transforming.
I think Milton is transforming a lot
of these absolutely central events in
Christian history into something
like scenes of digestion, uh,
for a very good reason. By, by turning,
by turning these moments into
little or big digestive episodes.
Milton's able on some level,
although this might sound irrational,
Milton's able to rationalize Christian
history that the process of digestion,
uh, was, uh, was, was an extraordinary
interest in the 17th century. And, and,
and scientists were fascinated
in it because digestion
seems like a lot of other
processes in the human body seems to
work without our own conscious knowledge
and certainly without our own control.
It's a digestion is a self enclosed
system that seems to obey its own natural
laws rather than responding
to an exercise of our,
of our will and Milton.
Imagine.
So much of the of Christian history has
at scenes of digestion in a way I think
because he needs to imagine them
as occurring without the deliberate
manipulation of the heavenly
father or without the,
or in some way beyond the
father's control. And,
and I think Milton is
continually fending off the,
the Calvinist image of an
arbitrary, uh, and punitive deity.
So the fall of the rebel angels, uh,
the fall of man, the last judgment,
all of these events are
perfectly reasonable,
natural and at least from one,
one important perspective in
the poem, reasonable, natural.
And also organic consequences
of freely willed,
self-determined human behavior
or creaturely behavior.
There they're not examples
of God's skiddish. And this
is important for Milton.
They're not examples of God's skiddish
and arbitrary punishment of his creatures.
And uh, that, that, that distinction is
a rising everywhere in paradise lost.
Now, book seven is the
book of creation. And,
and here more than
anywhere we would expect,
I think a representation of the
extraordinary degree of, of,
of power and control that the
heavenly father is able to exercise.
What is the creation after all,
if not an arbitrary display
of the fathers, omnipotence.
Uh, but Milton Milton knows that
that's the case, but at the same time,
at the same time that he celebrates that
he's also struggling to represent it
otherwise. And so we charge as even, uh,
the creation itself with this same
cluster of images involving digestion.
Look, for example, this is
the top of page three 52,
a book seven,
line two 34.
And I think this is one of
the most puzzling and for,
for a lot of reserves its readers,
it's one of the most physiologically
suggestive of all the natural processes
that seems to be described
in Milton's poem.
The Holy Spirit and the Holy Spirit
is an interesting entity for Milton.
It seems to be something like
Milton's name for the, uh,
principal of energy behind
a lot of natural processes,
a divinely sanctioned principle of energy.
The Holy Spirit inseminate it's chaos.
So this is Milton on the water.
Recall his brooding wings,
the spirit of God outspread and vital
virtue infused and vital warmth throughout
the fluid mass.
And Raefiel describes the Holy Spirit's
stunningly and where we're getting used
to this stunningly and sexual
behavior in brooding over.
And then of course, inseminating the
fluid mass of the abyss. This is, uh,
this is the process you'll remember that
actually supplies chaos with that vital
power of motion. Um, the vital power
of warmth and, and virtue that,
that so consequential for
Milton's theory of modernism. And,
and these are all ideas
that Milton discusses in a
theoretical frame in chapter
seven of, of, of Christian doctrine. Um,
there's seven days in creation and
Milton has a kind of numerological bent.
And so it will be in book seven of
Paradise Lost in which the creation has
discussed chapter seven of
Christian doctrine in which, uh,
in which the creation has
discussed. It's, it's this step,
this inseminating step in which in
which all of creation is filled with the
goodness of God. Um,
eh, that, that that's,
that's really at the end that goes to
the heart of Milton's theodicy because
this infusion of divinity, because
of it, everything that God creates,
every natural thing hass must
on some level be naturally good,
necessarily a good,
I think this much makes sense.
But,
uh,
but Raefiel also describes a moment in
the creation that's I think a little more
difficult for us to reconcile with what
we know or what we feel that we know of.
Milton's momism look how
this same passage continues.
This is line two 37,
but downward.
So this is the Holy Spirit is the
subject of the verb. But downward purged.
The black tartare is cold,
infernal dregs adverse to life,
then founded,
then can globe like things to like the
rest to several place discarded and
between spun out the air,
the Holy Spirit, downward purge,
the black tartare us gold,
cold infernal dregs adverse to life.
The Holy Spirit doesn't merely infused
chaos with vital virtue in vital warmth.
It purges something from chaos to,
and it's this,
it's this strange
digestive moment, um, in,
in Milton's text that has left students
in Milton's theology and students of the
poem scratching their heads and
bewilderment. And it's a and f.
And for some reason Milton is usually so
precise and really every word in every
image can almost always be accounted for.
But dregs were, this is the
question. Where did these,
where did these drugs come from?
Why are there any drugs in the
inseminated space of chaos,
um, that actually need to
be purged? God's infusion?
Think of the logic of Milton's creation.
God's infusion of vital virtue in vital
warmth should have completely filled the
matter of chaos with spirit and life
all matter, at least theoretically.
All matters should, uh, should be, uh,
should be steeped with spirit and energy.
And I,
and according to all of Milton's theories
of the this vitalist universe in the,
in the Christian doctrine,
there shouldn't be anything
in Milton's creation,
technically that's adverse to life.
Um, this really is crucial for Milton's
understanding of how the universe is put
together and it's crucial
to for his theodicy. Um,
but these drugs here are simply, this
is, there was no other way to read them.
They are dry, they are dead and they
are in [inaudible] and, and I'm,
I'm going to be applying some,
some pressure to these lines because what
we have here is a, is a moment of, of,
of some metaphysical incoherence.
And it's metaphysical incoherence at the
very heart of Milton's account of the
creation. And this, this incoherence
is announced with that wonderful word,
drags that Milton ways
down. Um, so much he,
he weighs it down with,
well for four contiguous adjectives.
Black Tartare is one, an awkward
line. Black Tartare is cold.
Infernal drags.
I've spent a lot,
I spent a lot of time thinking
about these lines and I've,
and I've also written about this problem
and so I'm going to ask you that,
ask you to permit me a little digression.
Um,
not that you really have a
choice, but I'm, I'm, I'm,
I'm just announcing to you this
fact that I will be digressing now.
And so what I'm going to
do is give you my theory.
My pet theory of Milton's
tartare is dregs. Um, okay.
I'm convinced here that
Milton is participating, uh,
in a contemporary conversation
involving one of his pet subjects,
one of his favorite subjects.
It's just that of digestion.
And this is a debate and it's certain,
it's not Milton's debate.
This is one that he inherits.
It's a debate about those indigestible
elements of food known as dregs in the
16th and 17th century,
also known as Tartar.
And I'm going to give you
a bit of information about
the renaissance philosophy
of Tartar and if you can believe,
believe that there is such a thing. Uh,
because I think it provides a good example
of just the kind of of seemingly cock
Cockamamie,
uh,
contemporary philosophical world,
um,
that a lot of early modern
intellectuals in habit,
the key figure in the science of dregs
and Tartar is the 16th century German
philosopher,
Paracelsus and literally
tartare is dregs there.
There's simply the residue,
the sediment produced by wine and,
and, and vinegar. And we still have a
substance and you're old if you cook,
you're familiar with this.
Um,
it's a substance made a vinegar sediments
and it's called cream of tartar. Well,
Paris had, Paracelsus had actually
developed an entire philosophy,
uh,
which had as its center,
his understanding of these
tartare is drags. So Tartar for,
for Paracelsus was the stuff that hardened
into stones within the gallbladder
and within the kidney or the explanation
for gallstones or kidney stones and
tartar was also the same material that
formed a hardened yellowish substance
that we still call of course
a tartar of the teeth.
And Milton in the 17th century would
have called it too at the Tartar.
And more commonly it was
known as tooth stone. And,
and for per Paracelsus,
if there's any natural substance on
this planet that can be identified on
equivocally with evil,
it is tartar and I need metaphysical evil.
And so given the import of this matter,
um,
Paracelsus was prompted to ask the same
question that we are all pumped to task
when were squirming on the dentist's
chair as we're having our teeth clean,
where in the hell does this
stuff come from? And, and,
and Paracelsus is answer to this
question was a theological one,
which is why I think Milton
was so interested in it,
although Milton eventually had to
reject it altogether. Now I'm of course,
I'm not suggesting that
the central context,
intellectual context for understanding
this part of paradise lost is the,
is the history of, of dentistry or the
history of oral hygiene. But it's, uh,
it's,
it's nonetheless,
we have in a moment of Milton's
engagement with a contemporary theory,
however, seemingly off the wall,
this is the theory of Tartar, um,
which was easily as theological
and philosophical in the
16th and 17th centuries
as it was dental. Okay. So for Paracelsus,
tartar originates in the food we eat.
And the Tartar that ends up on your
teeth is simply the indigestible
unassimilatable parts of that food.
And, and, and for a lot of Paracelsus,
his contemporaries, this was an
incredibly troubling theory. Um,
and a lot of Milton's contemporary
said so and so they had to reject the
parasail shun theory. Um, and you
can, and perhaps you could guess why,
because Paracelsus is theory
implied of course, that Tartar,
that tartar had been created by God.
It's part of the natural world,
and that God was somehow responsible
for the origin of evil in his creation.
And so you have philosophers
and theologians in the
17th century weighing in on
the, on the tartar question, on the
origin of dregs. And of course they,
there for the most part,
they're,
they're obliged to attack Paracelsus and
the entire tartar controversy and all
the things that this controversy suggests
about the nature of divine justice.
All of this, I think gets compacted into
this run. Truly extraordinary line. Um,
black tartare is cold infernal dregs.
And Milton is using this
incredibly striking,
strange and strange sequence of words
at this point in his creation account
because he wants to open up the
question for his contemporary audience.
Its core,
of course lost on us,
open up the question of the nature of
divine justice and Milton I think in, in,
in book seven is, is, is,
is relatively torn about the kind of
God that he wants so that he needs to
represent in the poem is Milton's
God, the punitive and, and,
and arbitrary God something like an
anthropomorphic deity or a god capable as
Paracelsus had suggested capable of
actually creating evil or is he a god that
we can identify with them more from a,
from a slightly later
Deist deistic perspective,
a God that we can identify with,
the more rational or the more natural
processes implied in the theory of monism
in which everything in God's creation is
just necessarily infused with divinity,
divinity and therefore good and alive and
for and in some way capable of virtue.
And this is a,
this is a type of question that Milton
is asking throughout throughout books
heaven,
a paradise lost.
And one of the ways that Milton
stages this problem is by turning for
inspiration is by turning to competing
sources of authoritative knowledge.
So Milton has on the one hand the
authority of scripture and you can see,
although scripture tells
us a lot of things,
one of the things that it
seems authoritatively to
tell us is that it gives us a
representation of the anthropomorphic
punitive deity, at least in the,
at least in the Hebrew Bible.
Milton also has to support this view more
or less the authority of a philosopher
like Paracelsus, um, who had
an image of a, uh, of a light,
a similar,
although differently configured image
of a punitive deity capable of creating
evil.
But what kind of authority does Milton
have for representing the other kind of
deity,
the force of life for the
energy that might actually
be much more rationally, uh,
recognizable or accessible
to a 17th century scientific
contemporary of Milton's
or we don't have a scientists
in the 17th century.
Technically we have natural
philosophers. Um, what is the form,
the basis of authority for
Contemporary Natural Philosophy?
And the question of authority and
authoritative knowledge is central to the
middle books.
Not just books haven't,
but to all the central
books of paradise lost.
Raefiel is presenting Adam and
eve with something like a quick,
a quick education in universal knowledge.
And the basis or the authority
for this knowledge is,
is constantly under
question in these books.
Because so much of rap yields
discourse has, has no foundation.
And this makes Milton nervous has no
foundation in scripture whatsoever.
The Bible simply can't be counted on
as an exclusive source of universal
knowledge.
And so Milton has no choice but to
turn to other forms of authority.
And one of them will is
science or natural philosophy.
And so Milton at the beginning of book
seven invokes the Muse of science,
the muse of astronomy at the beginning.
So look,
look at the end vocation.
This is page three 45 of the Hughes.
Um,
the opening lines.
It's here in book seven and only here
that Milton names his muse and the muse
turns out to be Urania. And she's
without question. Of course. She's a,
she's a feminine presence here.
And in the muses earlier
incarnations in books one and three,
there was some uncertainty as to whether
the heavenly spirit was a masculine
figure capable of impregnating chaos and
who will now impregnate Milton's mind
or whether the heavenly spirit
was a feminine spirit. Um,
a feminine power that dove likes that
brooding on the vast abyss or similarly
sat brooding on the,
the brooding mind of the poet.
But books seven is all about birth.
It's all about generation creation.
And Milton requires for this book,
I think an unequivocally feminine Muse,
a maternal Muse who was there,
who was there when the world was born
and who will serve here now as the,
as the nurturing mother of Milton
zone poem. Now Milton, who's, uh,
who's committed of course
to the truth of the Bible.
And similarly, um, committed,
at least in part to a lot of the truths
coming out in the world of natural
philosophy.
Milton's on shaky ground as he describes
the creation and is in vocation,
is filled with something like that.
And it just seems absolutely authentic.
A fear of religious error.
I'm look at line 19 Milton conjures
the fear of falling off Pegasus, the,
the Pegasus, the flying
steed of poetry, um,
erroneous there to wander.
And for Lauren and, and,
and book seven this especially this
invocation is the focus for an enormous
amount of Milton's poetic anxiety.
And,
and you can measure the degree of
Milton's poetic anxiety here by the
reappearance of that figure that Milton
has called on throughout his career at
moments of intense fear or
intensivist isolation. Uh,
and that's the figure of Orpheus.
Orpheus.
His mother was the Muse Calliope,
the Muse of epic poetry.
She had been incapable of saving her
son when he was dismembered by the
followers of Baucus,
the Buckeye,
Milton Implores Urania here at the
beginning of book seven to Outdo Calliope,
uh, to spare him the fate of
Orpheus. So look at line 30
still governed now my song uranium
and fit audience find though,
phew,
but drive far off the barbarous
dissonance of Bacchus and his revelers,
the race of that wild route that
tore the Thrace. Ian Born the tour,
the Thrace,
he and Bard and wrote a PE where woods
and rocks had ears to rapture till the
savage clamor drowned both harp and voice.
Okay.
Nor could the news defend her son.
Okay,
so fail not thou who the
employers for Thou art heavenly,
she an empty dream.
Now you're writing a is the traditional
name for the patroness of astronomy.
And if this music is astronomical,
wisdom is not truly governing Milton Song.
If she is nothing more than the projection
of Milton's most outrageous poetic
ambitions,
then Milton will have no
authority backing the poems.
Extraordinary claims to knowledge.
Milton Milton is,
I think really going out on a limb
[inaudible] paradise lost as he's claiming
what is essentially the,
the status of divine truth for thousands
of lines in this poem that really have
no foundation in holy scripture at all.
Think of what we've just read that I
have that I haven't spoken to at all.
Book six.
The story of the war in heaven is a
story that doesn't in effect appear,
um, in, in, in, in the Bible.
And there's a sense in this illusion
to Orpheus that this poetic endeavor of
Milton's is attended by the, by really
the profoundest risks, Milton implores,
the muse.
So fail not thou as calliope had failed,
of course Orpheus.
And,
and behind this cry lurks lurks the fear
that your rainy or to a kind of nagging
fear that Urania too may turn
out to be an empty dream.
The fear that Urania just like calliope
will turn out to be nothing more than a
conviction then a convenient
fiction dreamt up by, uh,
by a desperately ambitious poet.
Okay.
But there's another reason that
Milton is a, a feminine Muse here.
He wants in this next section of the
poem to espouse as to establishing a new
perspective for this book
of Universal Knowledge.
And he's relying on a new muse to liberate
him in some way from the strictures
of the Orthodox forms of
knowledge that are sanctioned.
So seeming so unequivocally,
um,
by the Bible and Milton
struggling to balance the,
the dominant theological
discourse with this new discourse,
this new language of science
or natural philosophy.
And so what you have in book seven is a,
is a really startling opposition of,
of essentially competing
forms of knowledge and
competing images of authority.
And Milton will invariably, how can they
not? And he does this authentically.
He acknowledges the validity
of a scriptural account
of a natural phenomenon,
but he will only do so,
um,
in order to set the scripture aside
at some point and begin to explore an
entirely different perspective,
an entirely different account
of the same phenomenon. Let's,
let's look at an example of, of, of
this. Um, at the bottom of page three 55,
this is book seven, line
three 87. This is what look,
look at what Milton does with
the genesis account of creation.
Here we have the, the fifth
day of creation. This is
when God, the god of genesis,
creates fish and fowl and Milton Milton
and begins the account here with a,
with a dutiful and humble
transcription of genesis.
And in some cases the word diverse is
actually a word for word transcription of
the King James Translation. In some
cases, the Geneva translation. Um,
and you can see the King
James Translation in the,
in the footnotes and sometimes not.
Milton will normally fiddle with just a
couple of words to make the genesis text
fit into the metrical scheme
of, of his blank. First lie.
Look at line three 87
and God said,
and God said, let the waters
generate reptile with spawn,
abundant living soul and let foul fly
above the earth with wings displayed on
the open firmament of heaven.
And God created the great whales and so
on and so forth up there all the way up
to three 98 and let the foul be
multiplied on the earth. And, and, and,
and these lines half have to be, and
they've certainly been cited as such. Um,
they've been cited as such
since the 18th century.
They have to be the flattest the least
interesting lines in the entire poem.
Um, and one of Milton's first
editors, this is on the handout. Um,
Dr. Bentley had actually argued that
these lines were so bad that they just
needed to be deleted
from the text altogether.
And Bentley's Bentley's thesis
wasn't a genius one that, uh,
Milton actually isn't responsible
for these lines at all. Um,
according to Dr. Bentley,
sometimes the Emmanuel Ncis,
the young man who had act as secretary
and take down the next installment of
lines are 15 lines or whatever,
um,
would you would just start making things
up or didn't hear Milton properly.
And so a lot of the lines that
Bentley's, uh, most disliked, um,
were to be dismissed for just this
reason that they clearly weren't,
had nothing to do with Milton's
Milton's own composition.
And so Bentley asks this question and
it's a, it's a, it's a good question.
Why should wrap the Elb so tied
up to the letter in Genesis,
Raphael,
who makes this narrative thousands
of years before genesis was writ not,
uh, not, not a bad question. If Raefiel
came before Moses long before Moses,
why is he quoting Moses,
Dr. Bentley reasonably asks,
and why indeed,
what might be the significance of
Milton's being tied up to the letter in
Genesis?
Milton begins his account of the
50th creation by paying homage to the
scriptural account of,
of,
to the scriptural source for
his own creation account.
But that's of course not
where Milton ends APP.
Look at line three 99 after
builtin has exhausted.
Thank God he's exhausted. His Bald
versification of the King James Bible.
He lets loose with an entirely
new representation of creation,
listened to this
forthwith the sounds and sees each creek
and bay with fry in numerable swarm and
shows a fish that with their fins and
shining scales glide under the greenwave
in schools that oft bank the mid.
See Milton takes the,
the austerity of genesis and amplifies
it with some of the lushest most
luxuriant verse in all of Paradise lost.
And I urge you all to read
these lines out loud in the,
in the privacy of your home.
So much of this poem has to
be experienced in your mouth.
I'm convinced before it
can fully be appreciated.
And this is in fact how
Milton experienced it. Uh,
he experienced it sonically because he
was blind and wasn't able to read it on
the page.
And,
and this and this particular description
of the fish and fowl continues for
another perfectly amazing 40 lines.
It's an extraordinary tour to
force that the sounds of water, uh,
of which Milton speaks at line 300
here are of course the bodies of water,
uh,
that,
that are suddenly filled with an an
enormous variety of aquatic life forms.
But the sounds that emerged forthwith
in this passage are also the sounds of,
of this amazing burst
of imaginative poetry.
The verse here explodes with the kind
of sonic energy that had been entirely
repressed or suppressed during Milton's
lifeless adherence to scripture and
shows a fish that with their
fins and shining scales,
Milton's swimming here, and he's loving
every moment of it. You know it in,
in essential alliterative verse that
almost completely drowns out our memory of
the bland King James English
of the previous lines.
And this demonstration of poetic strength
coincides with Milton's new sense of
the strength or the a new sense
of a force behind creation.
He takes the masculine image of God's
verbal command from Genesis and God said,
and he replaces it with an alternative
feminine conception of creation that
places the power of
creation in nature herself.
And in his description of his
description of the first schools of fish,
Milton I think is subscribing or can be
seen to subscribe to a new and daring
school of thought.
So look at line.
Look at the sixth day a
line for 50 Milton begins,
and we've seen him do this before.
He scrupulously follows the genesis
text and God, this is genesis.
And God said,
let the earth bring forth
the living creature after
his kind cattle and creeping
thing and beast of the earth
after his kind. And it was so,
and Milton reproduces the scriptural
description nearly verbatim,
but he very scrupulously omits
that final clause from genesis.
And it was so because he wonders,
well,
how was it?
So the genesis account of creation is
clearly inadequate here because it relies
on some mystical or some
magical fulfillment of the
father's divine command.
And it refuses.
Genesis refuses to provide a rational
or something like a natural explanation
for how the creation of cattle
and creeping thing came to be.
So now in the years of
the scientific revolution,
the later years of the 17th century,
the genesis account of creation was
coming under a lot of scrutiny. Um,
and the phrase and God said,
was increasingly seen
as this is an adequate,
this is an insufficiently be a believable,
a form of natural causation.
And there was a pressure felt by a lot
of intellectuals to imagine another form
and a more naturalistic force
or power of causation at work.
And this is exactly what
Milton himself does.
He replaces the biblical
phrase and it was so with,
uh,
with a spectacularly naturalistic
drama of what we can think of as self
creation. Look, look,
look what Milton does.
The earth obeyed and straight opening
her fertile womb team that a birth in
numerous living creatures,
perfect forms limbed and
full grown and invoking a,
a mother earth. Of course this mother
earth obeys the heavenly father,
but Milton by invoking her is
performing an operation, uh,
similar to the strategy that he had
performed in a, in the vocation.
He's countering the entirely masculine
force behind the genesis creation with a
new feminine presence that the female
Earth May just demonstrate her initial
obedience, uh, and
subordination to the father.
But after this,
a humbling of herself,
she's empowered to produce
and she does this on her own,
all of the numerous living creatures
and in Milton's imagining here a female
authority distinct from the authority
of the father who's issuing these verbal
commands at any depicts this new source
of creative power by drawing on a
literary authority, quite distinct
from the book of Genesis and the,
and the image of the earth opening up her
fertile womb actually comes from odds.
Metamorphosis.
Interestingly,
this comes from the section
of the metamorphosis that
describes a life after the
flood, the flood, Duke Aliens Flood,
seen as by by Christian
readers and Milton's day as
a classical version of the,
of Noah's flood.
So it's a fallen phenomenon that
Milton is placing well before the fall.
But what Milton does after this point
in this passage doesn't even have an
authority in all of it. Look at
light. Look at line four 63. Uh,
Milton begins to represent what may
have seemed to less courageous poets as
they're utterly unrepresented.
Representable this is the actual birthing
of these living forms. There are Imr,
the emergence of cattle and creeping
things from the fertile room of the living
earth.
Line four 63.
Okay,
this,
this gets me
the grassy Claude's now calved
the grassy Claude's now cab,
the grassy clods of earth are actually
opening up and giving birth to calves.
What, what is an amazingly daring
sequence of five, five words. Um,
it's a spectacular image of creation.
The grassy Claude's now calved now half
appeared the Tawney Lion Pine to get
free his hinder parts then springs as
broke from bonds and rampant shakes.
His Brendan Main,
you'll note at the bottom of the
page that Merritt who was tells us,
and I love this about you,
is that he gives us this
footnote that the romantic poets,
Samuel Taylor Coleridge had
singled out just this image,
the image of the tawny lion as
unworthy of Milton's gifts as a poet.
And you can see what offended Coleridge
and presumably also offends merit,
Merit Hughes. Uh, there, there's, there,
there is more than just a little
breach of decorum in this image of a,
of a lion wiggling his
bottom in order to free his,
his hinder parts.
Milton's not only portraying the
lions attempt to give birth to itself,
which is no small feat, um, as it pause
it's way out of the earth swollen.
He's also depicting something like a
liberation of sexual energy and there's an
emblem of the erotic charge that Milton
is giving so much of this non scriptural
material in, in, in, in book
seven of of Paradise lost.
And when the the lions
springs as broke from bonds,
there's a sense that Milton is
representing his own springing from the,
from the confining bonds of a scriptural
tradition that is insufficiently
literarily inspiring.
And it's also a liberation,
fully akin to his poetic escape,
will remember from the tyranny,
the bondage of rhyme.
Now throughout so much of paradise lost
the lines of hierarchical authority seem
to be an incredibly clearly drawn.
But in book seven,
Milton begins to experiment
a little more freely with,
with forms of authority and images of
hierarchy that actually counter, uh,
more of the,
the Orthodox notions that he finds in
the Bible or in fact that he finds in the
culture at large. And, and, and, and,
and the book itself is inspired by a,
by a distinctly feminine Muse and,
and its description of creation.
There's a significant significant
degree of autonomy granted to this,
this feminine power, the Earth,
this new phenomenon, the earth.
Now book eight would see in the semen
a lot of ways to put an end to this,
what would seem to be a provisional or
momentary celebration of Feminine Energy.
And in fact,
book eight seems to reassert
the subordination of
women to man that that had
characterized our first glimpse
of Adam and eve and book for,
um, you know, it's, you'll remember
that it's in book eight that,
that Adam or counts for Raefiel the
request that he had made to God for a,
for a partner, some fellow human, and
he specifically ask God for an equal.
This is a book eight line
three 82 four among unequals.
What society can sort,
what harmony or true delight Adam asks.
But God didn't seem all that interested
in granting Adam's request for an equal
partner.
And refferals continually urging Adam
to remember his superiority to eve.
He mustn't mistake gives beauty for
nobility or wisdom or, or equality.
And of course that has been Adam's
tendency and Rafio famously contracts his
brow when, when, when Adam
shows a tendency to, uh,
to idolize his wife.
And whenever the conversation
turns to Adam's relation to eve,
Raefiel expresses a fixed and inflexible
opinion on the matter of sexual
hierarchy. One sex clearly
has a priority over the other,
but,
but [inaudible] is also concerned
with another kind of hierarchy,
the hierarchy of the heavens. Uh, th the,
the relations of the heavenly bodies fuel
and Adam also in book eight discuss it
considerable length,
the relative position in the space of
the sun and the earth and the moon.
Does the sun travel around the earth,
uh,
which remains fixed at the
center of their universe as the,
as the medieval Ptolemy had argued or
does the earth revolve around the sun as
the early modern Copernicus?
And then later Galileo had theorized.
Adam of course, isn't certain though
it's certainly looks to him as if the,
as it looks to us as if the sun
moves around the earth. Now,
Adam's uncertainty here
is only reasonable,
but the remarkable aspect of this dialogue
is that the Archangel Raefiel isn't
certain either.
Redfield doesn't really know
which way the planets revolve,
even though he has spent much
of this very morning, um,
on his flight from heaven to Earth,
where presumably he had some opportunity
to observe the workings of the, of the,
of the heavenly planets.
It appears that God has made it difficult
even for the angels to discern the
hierarchical structure of the cosmos.
And there's an illegibility about
hierarchy of built into the system.
And of course by the mid 17th century,
the jury was still out as
to whether the universe, uh,
w was heliocentric or geocentric and
Milton wasn't alone in expressing some
uncertainty. And you know, you could say,
and it has been said that it was wise
of him to hedge his bets. But there's,
there's a lot more going on in
the discussions of astronomy than,
than just a serious desire to get to
the bottom of a difficult contemporary
scientific question there.
There's way too much made of raffles
confusion here and his uncertainty about
cosmic hierarchy,
that the sun and the earth
or the sun and the moon are,
are deliberately gendered.
Here Milton uses the traditional gender
assignments of these heavenly bodies
that,
that he inherits from the Latin language
and he holds to them scrupulously
throughout the poem.
This,
so the sun is always masculine and the
earth and the moon are always feminine.
And,
and the,
and the controversy about the priority
of the heavenly bodies is in some way
Milton's reformulation of the controversy
about the priority of the sexes.
That the field of astronomy provides.
Milton with a something like a
scientific discourse about the sex is an
alternative source of knowledge that
permits him to counteract the more
traditional,
the more theological account of the sexes,
uh, assimilable from his culture,
but also from, from, from the Bible.
Look at page three 66 in the Hughes.
Raphael's a certainty about
sexual hierarchy in the
human sphere seems to give
way to nothing but doubts and uncertainty.
As soon as that hierarchy is extended to
the cosmic sphere and science provides
a different kind of space, this is a
discursive space for a more liberated,
a more open ended discussion of,
of sexual politics.
And it provides Milton with an opposing
source for the knowledge about the
sexes, um, uh,
knowledge that seemed so complete and
so sewn up from the theological point of
view. Implicit in the genesis account.
So on page three 66, this is book eight,
line one 48. Raefiel, uh,
is beginning to grow
exceedingly speculative here.
And he dares to conjecture that there
may exist out there in the cosmos,
other sons and other moons,
other sons,
perhaps with their attendant moons,
thou wilt describe communicating
male and female light,
which two great sexes animate the world
stored in each or perhaps with some that
live the two great sexist here,
communicate that, communicate their light.
Um,
do so with an equal brilliance that the
greatness of one isn't emphasized here,
at least in these lines at
the expense of the other.
And you'll remember with Adam and eve and
our first description of them in there,
Naked Majesty,
they were lords of all and
presumably equally lords of all.
And when Raefiel conjectures that some
creatures might actually live on these
infinitely distant other
sons and other moons,
he's pointing to an alternative conceptual
world in which the relation of the
two great sexes might, might be
configured, um, altogether differently.
Um,
Rafio concludes the discussion at,
at line one 59 and he
suggested essentially to Adam
bet it's not Adam's place.
Adam should just cool it.
It's not his place to pursue these grand
questions of heavenly organization.
So this is Raefiel. But whether
thus these things or whether or not,
whether the sun predominant in heaven
rise on the earth or earth rise on the
sun, it's a IRAP fields just telling
us that simply doesn't matter.
And he suggests a decisive
if such a thing makes sense.
So the decisive uncertainty about whether
the predominant sunrises on the earth
or whether their predominant
earth rises on the sun and,
and one Milton critic John Guillory has,
has been absolutely right.
I think he's the best reader of this.
A whole problem in suggesting that
we can hear behind these lines.
The brooding question of sexual hierarchy,
is the,
is the man on top or is the woman on top?
Is the,
is the masculine sex predominant or,
or could it be that the
feminine predominates and
when speaking about the sex is
in the language of human
relations, Rapheal is utterly
definitive about who, uh,
about who predominates over whom. But when
he's speaking the language of science,
he seems baffled and is,
it's lovable.
His confusion in the scientific
realm can be seen to,
to force us to reconsider his certainty
about relations in the human realm and
the ethical realm.
Now,
none of this is to say
that the Milton is a,
is a feminist or,
or,
or even that Milton is a protofeminist
that the question of what,
what Milton actually believes
about the priority of the sexes is,
is really I think too difficult
to discover or extract
simply from a reading of
the text. Um, this,
this poem is far too filled
with contradictions to give
us anything like a clear
roadmap, uh, to Milton's own beliefs.
If it could even be said that he or
any of us actually have firm and fixed
beliefs about such huge and consequential
matters as the relation between the
sexes. But I, but it is,
I think it is possible to see that Milton
is struggling to hold in solution to
keep in some way to keep in suspension
the competing sources of knowledge that
address this crucial question in paradise
lost the question of the relation
between the sexes and,
and Milton's poem is,
I mean we can't deny this.
This is a far more theological
poem then it is a scientific one,
but Milton will nonetheless use
the language of natural philosophy,
the language of science,
to open up some of the pressing questions
that his theology seems to have closed
down.
And you can see Milton Milton willingly
placing himself in the role of Rafiel at
just those moments when the
archangel is discussing astronomy,
it's as if Milton just
like that affable angel.
And don't you love it that Milton lets
us know that without Raefiel is the
affable angel quite quite unlike the
Michael that we moment in the last two
books.
It's as if Milton just like Raefiel,
we're throwing his hands
affably up in the air.
I'm in complete uncertainty and
telling us the readers, I dunno,
I don't know the answer to these
big questions. You decide, okay.